charles haas yen cher alsacien nous
sommes tous voisins nous sommes tous
solidaires
ces derniers mois dans les villes et
dans les villages vous avez été des
dizaines de milliers à donner de votre
temps où faire oeuvre de générosité dans
la lutte contre le coronel et russe sans
cet élan de générosité rien n'eut été
possible c'est grâce à cette entraide
spontané que nous avons pu faire face à
la pandémie
la crise sanitaire est apaisé mais
encore réel nous faisons face à un
immense défi social et économique
aussi cette solidarité de proximité doit
plus que jamais se poursuivre une
société qui s'entraide entre voisins
entre générations dans les immeubles me
sied dans les associations entre les
entreprises les services publics et les
collectivités
c'est une société qui est plus unie et
donc plus forte pour faire face
collectivement aux vicissitudes de la
vie
c'est pourquoi votre conseil
départemental du haut rhin a décidé de
poursuivre et d'amplifier cet élan de
solidarité et de bienveillance en
mettant à votre disposition gratuitement
une plateforme d'entre aide appelée
voisin tir est solidaire point haut rhin
point fr avec la plateforme voisin tir
est solidaire point haut rhin point fr
chacun peut aider ou être aidé vous avez
un besoin faites le connaître vous avez
un savoir faire
vous voulez donner de votre temps vous
souhaitez faire don de matériels de
choses essentielles faites le savoir
chacun de ses coups de mains doivent
être désintéressée donc sans échange
commercial ce peut être par exemple
ramener les comptes du voisin offrir les
fruits de son verger prêté du matériel
donner un coup de main pour du bricolage
faire de l'aide aux devoirs
chèrs hassiane cher aux alsaciens nous
sommes tous oisans nous sommes tous
solidaires
rendez vous est donné sur la plateforme
voisin tir est solidaire points or un
point fr nous comptons sur vous